Man 1: We've been discussing
this amazing second paragraph of the
Declaration of Independence.
We've gotten through what passes
for the first two sentences.
They use all sorts of
weird punctuation here.
Now they're going on to
say, "That whenever any form
"of government becomes
destructive of these ends,
"it's the right of the
people to alter or abolish it
"and to institute new
government, laying its foundation
"on such principles as
organizing its powers
"in such forms as to them
shall seem most likely
"to affect their safety and happiness."
Man 2: Just to make sure
I, because they're writing
in a very -
Man 1: They get a bit
ornate in this (crosstalk)
They edit that first sentence a whole lot,
so it's very clear, but this
sentence is a little bit ornate.
Man 2: When they write,
"That whenever any form
"of government becomes
destructive of these ends,"
they're talking again of the
life, liberty, and the pursuit
of happiness.
Man 1: Right. (crosstalk)
In other words, if you have
a king who's taken away
people's life, liberty, and
the pursuit of happiness.
This is, they're talking
about the English government,
not just the Parliament,
but the king now has become
destructive of these unalienable rights
that we're supposed to protect.
Man 2: Yeah and that we
then form a new government
to affect their safety and happiness.
Man 1: Right, but most
importantly, it's the right
of the people to alter or abolish it.
In other words, they're saying something
that has not yet been
quite accepted by history,
which is if you're a
people and you don't like
your government, you can overthrow it.
We hadn't had that many revolutions
in the past 200 years leading up to that
and this is the beginning
of an age of revolution,
where people say, "Oh
yeah, we have the right
"to abolish our government."
Woah, that's a holy cow.
Man 2: It's the people
doing it, not another king,
not another ruler.
That's most of history, is other kings.
Man 1: Exactly, most of
history, for the 100 years
leading up to this
document, France and England
have been fighting each other.
The kings of England have
been trying to supplant
the kings of France and
there's been a 100 Years War,
it's been ...
The American Revolution's
sort of a part of that,
but something different happens here.
It's not one king trying
to overthrow another king,
it's the right of the people
to abolish and institute
a new government to
protect their own safety
and happiness.
The next sentence, "Prudence,
indeed, will dictate
"that governments long
established should not
"be changed for light
and transient causes."
That, basically, is saying
you shouldn't go around doing
this all the time.
You have to have a really,
really good reason,
because it's not as if
just because you're kind of
annoyed at your government
you should overthrow it.
This is why they have a
pretty long document ahead
of them.
This is just the first two paragraphs.
Man 2: This is important.
I guess, from my (unintelligible)
of what this whole document is for.
This is to communicate
with the rest of the world
and as you mentioned,
also France, that look,
we're not crazy folks here.
We recognize this is a
serious thing we're doing.
We don't take this lightly.
Man 1: That's what this
sentence says exactly,
which is you shouldn't
do it just for light
and transient causes.
We're going to have to
show you that we've got
some real good reasons to do it.
That's what it goes on to say.
Especially like, "while
evils are sufferable
"than to right themselves
by abolishing the forms
"to which they are accustomed."
In other words, these
are powerful words saying
that these are the type
of things you really have
to raise up arms against.
Then, let's go to this sentence.
Oh sorry.
Man 2: I find this one really interesting.
It's kind of a less famous
part of it, but it says,
"and accordingly all experience hath shown
"that mankind are more disposed to suffer,
"while evils are sufferable
than to right themselves
"by abolishing the forms to
which they are accustomed."
It's really saying that, normally, men,
even when their rights start
to get imposed, they just -
Man 1: Go along with it.
Man 2: It's kind of like
a frog in boiling water.
They just live with it, but
when it gets too bad ...
Man 1: Yeah, that's when
you have to take up arms.
You're right, the whole point of that is
that experience has shown
we kind of just go along
with bad kings, just like
we go along with good kings.
This is special, this is
different, what they're saying
and that's why they
start the next sentence
with the word "But".
It's sort of the, "but this
is different," sentence.
Why is it different?
"But when a long train of
abuses and usurpation ..."
Usurpation means they're
taking away our powers.
"... Pursuing invariably the
same object evinces a desire
"to reduce them under absolute despotism."
In other words, what's
happened is the king
and his parliament have
decided to reduce it
so that they have all the powers.
They're taxing without our consent,
they're doing all sorts of things.
They're quartering troops in our homes.
That's when it goes on to
say, "it is their right."
In other words, the right of our people.
"... it is their duty to
throw off such government
"and to provide new guards
for their future security."
Think about that.
How often had that been happening before?
Man 2: Yeah, especially
for the people to do it.
Man 1: Right.
We very rarely have had
a people-led rebellion
to say you've usurped.
There's usurpation.
You've usurped our rights.
There's been a long train
of abuses and you've reduced
us to absolute despotism.
Actually, Jefferson, when
he writes that phrase,
has an even grander
phrases (unintelligible)
everything else and Franklin says,
"I think we're going a bit overboard here.
"Let's just 'say reduce them
under absolute despotism',"
which means you've taken
away all our rights.
You've become a despot.
Man 2: Yeah.
Man 1: Then it goes on
to say, "Such has been
"the patient sufferance
of these colonies."
In other words, we've been
pretty patient up until now.
You put on a tea tax,
you put on a paper tax,
you put on a stamp act,
taxation without representation.
You haven't allowed us to
be part of the Parliament,
voting on our own taxes.
We've been pretty patient of these things
"and such is now the necessity
which constrains them,"
meaning constrains us, the
people of the United States,
"to alter their former
systems of government,"
and now is when they set up
what is going to be the rest
of the document.
They attack the king.
The history of the present
king of Great Britain.
We have him up there,
George III, there he is.
Looking kind of nice, like (crosstalk)
He looks definitely like a
royal person, but the history
of this present king of
Great Britain is a history
of repeated injuries and usurpations.
" ... all having in direct
object the establishment
"of an absolute tyranny
over these states."
You know what?
I think they were overstating it a bit.
I'm not trying to be
kind to King George here,
but what they did is they tax
the tea, they tax the stamp,
they were using the tax
revenues to help support
the colonies.
I think Parliament felt that
you could argue a little bit
that we're taxing without
getting your consent,
but I think they would say,
"Hey, wait, absolute tyranny?
"Repeated injuries and usurpation?"
They're going too far and
there was a lot of people,
at least half the people in the colonies,
that kind of agreed with the English.
They were still loyal.
So, what they do, Jefferson,
Franklin, and Adams,
and the people writing this, is they say,
"We're going to have to
show you why we're using
"this strong language."
It's a wonderful sentence to me.
"To prove this, let facts be
submitted to a candid world."
That's what this declaration is.
We're going to give you all
the facts and try to prove
it's been absolute tyranny
that we've been suffering
and they worked themselves
up into convincing
themselves and probably
the rest of history.
Man 2: And to be fair to
them, probably in 1774,
or even March of 1775, they
might have felt like that,
but there was bloodshed now.
People have been killed
and now, of course,
people are going to be
much more passionate
about the situation.
Man 1: I guess you could
sense it in your own sense
of history.
Once people start fighting,
they get themselves a bit
worked up.
Man 2: Absolutely and it's British troops
on American soil.
It's American families,
American fathers who are dying.
That's how I can imagine they would start
to see these things.
Man 1: Right.
It starts to get out of hand
without their intention.
The continental congress
didn't declare war
back in 1775.
You have a bunch of
militia people in Lexington
and Concord getting all
riled up by Paul Revere,
because the British
are coming to take some
of the munitions out of
the arsenals in Lexington
and Concord.
He's riding and saying
the British are coming
and then the militiamen
come out and suddenly,
up in Massachusetts, this
revolution that even most
of the people in the
continental congress weren't
quite ready for, has
begun to happen and ...
(crosstalk)
Man 2: After this, they go on and list.
Man 1: That's the rest of the document.
The rest of the Declaration
is just line after line
of the king has done this,
the king has done that,
and most importantly, as you see in this,
the history of the present
king of Great Britain,
they're revolting now against the king,
not just the Parliament
that has voted these taxes,
but they're saying it's the king himself
that we're rebelling against
and that's what made it
a true revolution, rather
than just trying to get rid
of the Parliament, which is temporary.
Man 2: Fascinating.